مرحبًا ،
أنا دانا سانتس مدرب للتنفس
والجسم الذهني في الرياضات الاحترافية ،
أريد أن أشارك أربعة تمارين
روتين قبل النوم يجب أن
تقوم بها
كل ليلة للحصول على نوم جيد ليلاً في
كثير من الأحيان يصعب علينا النوم بسبب
الأوجاع الشائعة  والآلام التي تجعل من
الصعب عليك النوم
أو إيقاظنا في الليل ،
تعالج هذه التمارين المناطق التي
نشعر فيها بهذا النوع من الألم
والتوتر ، لذلك دعونا نجربهم ،
هذا التمرين الأول مهم حقًا
لإرخاء الظهر الضيق.
ستبدأ العضلات بالوقوف بجوار سريرك وتريد
أن تكون قادرًا على التمسك بشيء
إما في تذييل
السرير ، والحاجز الجانبي ، كما أن لدي
هذه المنشورات حتى أتمكن من التمسك بالوظيفة
ولكن أقف على مسافة الورك  بصرف النظر
عن ذلك
، ستتمسك بالسرير وتترك كل وزنك
يتراجع عندما تدخل في وضع القرفصاء
الآن من هذا الوضع ،
سنأخذ ثلاثة إلى خمسة
أنفاس عميقة طويلة ، وسأخذ ثلاثة معك
ثم  لطيف على سبيل المثال  حسنًا ،
لكن زفيرًا كاملاً ، لذا تأكد من أنك
تزفر شهيقًا
كبيرًا تمامًا مرة أخرى ممتدًا من خلال ظهرك
ولاحظ أيضًا أنك تترك
وزنك يتراجع إذا تركت
هنا ، فسأعود
حرفيًا لذا فقط تمسك
بسريرك  الزفير
ثم مرة أخرى شهيقًا واسعًا
وازفر زفيرًا مريحًا ، اشعر بأكتافك
مسترخية ثم أعد نفسك بلطف.
تم تصميم هذا التمرين التالي لتحرير
التوتر في عضلات
الفخذ لدينا وجسمنا الجانبي بحيث عندما نستلقي
للاسترخاء ،
يمكن أن نمد أجسادنا حقًا
إلى الخارج ، لا نشعر كما لو
أننا ما زلنا عالقين في وضع الجلوس ،
فقد تتعرف على هذا
من اليوجا كمحارب ،
إما أن تضع يدك على
سريرك أو على وركك  ارفع الذراع المعاكس
ثم أخرج الزفير وقم بالوصول ،
والآن لدي قدمي اليمنى
أمام اليسار والظهر وأنا
أمد عضلات فخذي اليسرى ،
وأخذ ثلاثة
أنفاس وأتذكر أن التوازن يمثل مشكلة بالنسبة لك
يمكنك فقط التمسك
بسريرك واستنشاقه مرة أخرى
لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانك التمدد
بشكل أعمق قليلاً وأنفاسًا أخرى
جيدة ومن ثم إعادة نفسك مرة أخرى
ولدينا جانبان لجسمنا ،
لذا سنريد التبديل إلى
الجانب الآخر الآن
نتذكرك  سأقلب نفسك إذا كنت
حقًا بحاجة إلى السرير للحصول على الدعم ،
فأنا لا أضع يدي على فخذي
والآن سأقوم بإطلاق عضلات الفخذ اليمنى
وسأصل إلى الذراع الأيمن لأعلى ثلاثة
أنفاس زفير
تعرف على ما إذا كان بإمكانك التعمق قليلاً
ونفَس أخير
الآن عندما تفعل ذلك بنفسك ، يمكنك
دائمًا أن تأخذ
خمسة أنفاس أكثر من أي شيء تشعر أنه
صحيح ، لكن القيام بثلاثة على الأقل ،
سيساعد هذا التمرين على تحرير
الأجزاء الخارجية من الوركين وعضلات الأرداف
لذلك يُطلق على جانبك الخلفي اسم الحمام أو الشكل الرابع
على السرير ،
لذا سترفع ساقك لأعلى ثم
ربما يظل بعضكم
مستقيماً تمامًا لأن وركيك
مشدودان حقًا ، فلا بأس بذلك
طالما أنك تشعر بالإفراج.  ولا
ألم في ركبتك
إذا كنت صغيرًا  إذا كان الأمر أكثر مرونة ،
فستكون قادرًا على البدء في التقدم ،
فقط
ابق في المكان الذي تكون فيه
مريحًا ، ثم خذ ثلاثة إلى خمسة
أنفاس عميقة طويلة ،
وسأخذ ثلاثة أنفاس معك ، لذلك
دعونا نستنشق
هذا الزفير بشكل لطيف وكبير ونطيل هذا الزفير حقًا
لأننا نحاول الاستعداد للنوم ، نريد
زفيرًا أطول يريح أنفسنا
ثم نعيد الشهيق
والزفير مرة أخرى
ثم نخرج برفق وحذر
وننتقل إلى الجانب الآخر
ثم مرة أخرى ثلاثة إلى خمسة أنفاس
سآخذ ثلاثة معك ،
لذا دعنا
نستنشق زفيرًا مريحًا
إذا شعرت أنه يمكنك الانحناء
للأمام قليلاً ، ثم قم
باستنشاق النفس الأخير
وزفر كتفيك
ثم نرفع ساقك برفق
من السرير
ثم  لدينا تمرين
آخر ، هذا الأخير هو تطور
فقط للتخلص من أي توتر متبقي
أحب هذا لأنه في بعض الأحيان عندما
أفعل ذلك ، أحصل على القليل من البوب في ظهري ، يبدو الأمر وك
نه إصدار رائع ، لذا آمل أن
شعر بنفس ال
يء  سنبدأ بركبتنا اليمنى تتجه نحو
صدرنا ، خذ يدك اليسرى إلى الخارج
من تلك الساق ،
تخرج الذراع اليمنى إلى الجانب ثم
نستخدم
الزفير لتحريف تلك الساق إلى
اليسار
الآن سنمسك بهذا مثل  لدينا
التدريبات الأخرى لمدة ثلاثة إلى خمسة
أنفاس تقررها ، لكنني سآخذ ثلاثة
أنفاس
معك ، شهيقًا كبيرًا لطيفًا
، وأشعر حقًا أنك
تستنشق الجاذبية عند استنشاق هذا الزفير ،
يمكنك البدء في إغلاق عينيك
مرة أخرى
زفيرًا مريحًا حقًا  أعد ساقيك
إلى
الوسط ، والركبة اليسرى تصعد يدك اليمنى إلى
الخارج من الرجل
اليسرى والذراع الأيسر للخارج إلى الجانب ، وأدير رأسي
لإلقاء نظرة عليها ثم
الزفير والدوران إلى اليمين
مرة أخرى فقط في كل زفير
ستمنح الجاذبية
ثلاثة أنفاس هنا ، لذا
استنشق بدايةً لإغلاق عينيك
، ثم أخرج أنفاسًا أخرى ثم أخرج زفيرًا
واستمر في
عمل رائع ، وبعد الانتهاء من
التمارين الأربعة ،
ستشعر بالراحة في
جسدك.  حيث تم تحرير كل
التوتر وحان الوقت للدخول إلى سريرك والنوم